well joining me now is dr. Rob hunter
who is the head of flight safety at the
British Air Line Pilots Association well
/ thank you for being with us on the
assumption that things happen as the
french prosecutors believe they did is
there anything about british airlines
and British airline pilots which means
that this couldn't have happened well I
think the checks on pilots are very
rigorous amongst the greatest of any of
the occupations really they have very
intensive simulator checks so if this is
if this terrible disaster was caused by
a psychological illness and that makes
it very difficult to complete the
simulator checks which are very demand
when you're saying you think the British
airline powers have better psychological
checks and Germans for example I
wouldn't say that they're necessarily
better but I thought you think they're
robust what about the technical things
that sees have happened the possibility
of one pilot being left on the flight
deck alone and being able to lock out
the other pilot that they'll happen on a
British play that could have happened
yes yes how do you think there is a need
to to possibly change the rules that's
been taught well I think this certainly
those result of this disaster there's a
need to look at the to investigate the
accident and to learn from it that's how
aviation safety achieves its huge safety
record it's a sort of Darwinian approach
you you look to see what caused this and
then seek to eliminate it in the future
because as I understand it one of the
ironies is the ability to lock the
cockpit is actually sort of anti-terror
precaution that's right and it shows you
how these measures can be very
percussive so they have to be thought
through and analyzed from what you've
heard and what you've seen do you have
any doubt that this did happen that one
one person decided to crush this play
and take his own life and those of
everyone else on board I can only go on
what the french prosecutors have said
and they they seem to have no doubt but
i can't really speculate beyond that it
is a completely extraordinary event
though have you come across suicide by
pilot before I haven't actually and I've
got a lot of experience in this area
I mean because it does seem
extraordinary that killing yourself
could blind you to the fact that you are
killing so many other people or indeed
that you would want to kill so many
other people it is and for example it's
not a typical consequence of depression
for example the the problem with
depression in flying is the reduction in
your cognitive abilities it's not this
risk of killing yourself or others
really what what are the psychological
tests which are conducted on on pilots
which could rule them out for applying
okay well in addition to the simulator
checks that I was talking about they'll
have to pass their medical evaluation
they'll have to make a declaration of
their medical fitness any psychological
problems and their aviation medical
examiner will then follow up on anything
that either the pilot has reported or
that they pick up on there's also a
system of peer support and peer
intervention so there's a culture in
aviation of reporting problems in other
pilots so really there's quite a good
safety culture and set of systems in
time I mean are you obliged and in
violation if you don't report the fact
that you're seeking psychological help
for a medical authorities absolutely
it's criminal offence not to when would
that be something which would
automatically lead to your suspension
from flying planes and not necessarily
if you declare a psychological problem
or a depression it needs to be being
assessed now the initial stage of that
assessment might might happen with you
being grounded whilst evidence is
gathered but pilots can be assessed
following depressive illness and minor
psychological illness and if treated and
there are no longer symptomatic and
well-controlled then it is possible to
return to flying and do you feel that
looking at this now that there will be
people who are more worried about flying
and should they be more worried I think
inevitably that we've people are more
worried about flying but as to should
they while flying is extraordinarily
safe and remain so so the the
performance of the aviation industry is
is exemplary when competitor as you say
the beginning we have to learn from
these
winces what changes will you about
probably calling for to make sure it
doesn't happen again however unlikely it
is well that's so dependent on the
results of the investigation and we
really don't know you know what was in
this sick note what the illness was what
sir you know what was going through his
mind on that day and then in terms of
what measure what measures you take as I
said they can be very percussive so it's
important not just to go into a sort of
knee-jerk reaction it really is a matter
for very careful consideration in due
course